so San Diego Comic-Con Source Nani
getting the release of an invincible
season 2 trailer but we also got a
special episode of the show on Prime
video titled Invincible presents Adam
Eve this perfectly adapted to issue
comic series of the same name the entry
itself tells the origin story for Eve
and its centers around her discovering
her past along with Elias braniewith in
one of the best trailer Easter eggs I've
ever seen you can actually catch the
pair together if you go back to that
first season 2 trailer sat to the left
of the screen we can see the pair
together and the creative team have
confirmed that they did this to tease
what was coming they even were out here
asking about Theory time so you know I
could let them down when it came to a
breakdown of this episode throughout
this video we're going to be going
through everything that happens in it
and also discussing some of the changes
from the comics if you're as excited as
I am to be talking about Invincible
again then please hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns on season 2. without the way
I'm your host Paul now let's get into
atom Eve
[Music]
to the episode it's almost like a
one-to-one copy of the original comic
but it does start off differently to how
the book began in that we started
immediately with Dr brandyworth
escorting Samantha's mother into labor
right here we begin with a big action
scene things start off with the lizard
League which in case you don't know or a
play on the serpent Society Prince
lizard is voiced by Jacob Tremblay and
he also plays the pot of phase two later
on now the lizard League's first
appearance in the comics actually had
them trying to steal a canister which is
when they were stopped by both
invincible and Adam Eve there we met the
Lizard King whereas this entry has
prince and Queen along with their
subject Queen lizard is voiced by none
other than taty Animas Lani and this is
the second time she's gone Green in the
comic book Show recently with her also
playing She-Hulk that joined by
salamander who's played by Phil Lamar
and we learned that they're looking for
a special serum however the reign of
terror doesn't last too long and lots of
the main members of the Guardians of the
globe then drop in when we last saw them
they were getting smashed like it was
the like button but here we see back in
the day before omniman played his hand
amongst the ranks are Immortal man and
Aquarius a play on Aquaman but he's just
a full-on fish now both are voiced by
Ross Marquand who you might know from
Robert kirkman's of the big TV show
which is of course The Walking Dead as
black Samson the green ghost stanlast
the war woman who's also voiced by The
Walking Dead's Lauren Cohen such a great
way to kick start the episode and I
think if you go back and watch this
before starting season one it's gonna
add some extra oomph to when omniman
takes them all out in the comics they
didn't actually die until Issue 7 but
Kirkman wanted to leave the first
episode of the series with a a Breakneck
twist sorry about that now they
mentioned the Batman equivalent Darkwing
flash counterpart red rush and lastly
Martian Man Who is a play on Martian Man
Hunter now that they're putting up a
good fight against them we learn
warwoman's calling the reserves in the
form of omniman they have a little joke
about all the heroes having the first
letters of their names on their chest
which is is of course seen in both Omni
man and Immortal man this is also
reflected in Mark with the Invincible
having an eye on it that was actually
meant to be a nod to the book's
publisher Image Comics they talk about
Omni man's original white suit which was
worn by the veltromites during that
mission of Conquest Omni man's been
given an uptake by the Taylor AKA art
Rosenbaum and in the series he's voiced
by Mark Hamill he was the one who gave
Mark his iconic costume all the way back
in episode 1 and I actually think
they're doing a little joke about his
lack of design skills why I'm saying
that is because the letters on the chess
thing plays off later on as Adam evens
up having molecules as a symbol instead
she doesn't just go with this the cliche
letter thing because she actually makes
her own costume and just shows how the
tail is kind of reduced to doing this
with every hero and while all this is
going on we see what's happening on the
other side of the serpent Society attack
this is a slight differentiation from
the comics as there weren't any
explosions when we joined them but here
the two events are tied together we
learned that brandyworth originally just
just wanted a diversion from them but
it's gone far beyond that whereas in the
book they just rode out to the hospital
the journey was in an ambulance in the
source material whereas here it's in
brandyworth's car and it allows them to
at least have a heart to heart now it's
cheering this that he promises to look
after her child and we also get similar
moments that include the pink eyes all
parents have experienced pink eye in
some form or another but this is
slightly different and it signals off
before she screams just before her
apparent death and we'll discuss what
happens later on but in both moments
Erickson ends up storming the hospital
voiced by Lance Reddick the actor Sally
passed away earlier in the air not sure
what his final performance is as there
are rumors he's going to be in the
ballerina but it did kind of bum me out
realizing he never got to see this now
brandyworth has passed the baby under
two parents who as we learn have just
lost their child this is Adam and Betsy
Wilkins he'll now raise Samantha
believing that she's in fact theirs just
like the comics we end with a scene with
them announcing her name and at the this
point we then cut to the titles
[Music]
Invincible is now swapped out with Adam
Eve with us getting the atomic
reorganization that the character wields
as their powers I always kind of thought
that she was Loosely based on molecule
man from Marvel Comics as he could
arrange matter at will and change the
structure of objects might not be the
case but Alice Phoebe leaves which is we
then get a montage of Samantha's early
life I'm guessing the witch's thing is
not discolor which who of course also
has reality warping Powers now one of
the scenes missing from the show is when
Samantha's carried out the hospital and
she looks over and sees Elias looking on
from an alley she calls out baba and he
then disappears which gives us the idea
that he's always gonna look after her
now in the show he also ends up looking
homeless later on whereas in the comics
he always kept his lap code so no no it
was expensive to buy new clothes now
instead the Montage we got her parents
trying to get her to say her first words
before we cut to the babysitter who's
brought across perfectly for the show
voiced by Philip Solomon Zach realizes
she's a chemistry genius which makes him
us to her parents they have to enroll
her in a special school for youngsters I
always wondered if this was playing off
Xavier's School for gifted youngsters
but we never see anyone with superpowers
at the Academy now in the comics it's
called Saint francis's school for
exceptional youths whereas here it's
named after Rosalind Franklin this was a
British chemist and her work was
Paramount in understanding DNA both
scenes in the show and Burke have a
lives watching over here but in the
source material she sees them rise here
she doesn't now from yowie courtesy
Rogers and Erickson's experiments and
they're currently running a phase two
tests unlike Adam Eve these new kids can
manipulate living tissue but this has
left their skin and body in a constant
state of flux almost completely confined
to a stasis tube he and his brother or
Chrono hate their sister because they
don't live up to her anyway from here
the series adds a new character in val
who didn't appear in the source material
in the comics they Kurt from the shot of
allies at the school window to Eve at
home in the aftermath of being kicked
out actually really appreciate edition
of Val and it kind of shows out Samantha
wants a normal life she realizes she's
never really going to be accepted though
and she feels isolated in both her
school and social life now they do kind
of play on the school quitting thing
later on but they alter things depending
on what version you pick up in both
Samantha calls the other kids at the
school freaks and her dad makes a
comment about how she's won too in the
comics though she storms out saying that
she wishes she was adopted which yeah be
careful what you wish for anyway in both
versions she ends up discovering her
powers at this point with her turning a
book into a glass in the episode in the
book her mother brought her a sandwich
which he turned into a cheeseburger
which we then get playing out after the
book test Blown Away by her powers she
then shows this off to Val who's
completely freaked out by what she can
now do it hammers home the idea that she
is actually a freak and it makes her
decide to go on her own kicked out of
school at his point she goes to a
regular one and we see that she's got no
mate her aunt does get her a lovely
lovely dress though and this is
brilliantly brought across from the
comics but in those she then changes it
into winter clothes she also doesn't try
and turn a squirrel into a puppy but it
does ACT well to actually lead into the
next scene involving the dogs in that
she showed up with a black balaclava at
the blue whereas here we see her making
a mask and also developing her platform
Powers they perfectly play out the scene
with them even calling her a Powerpuff
Girl and their balaclavas then get
turned into metal Elias arrives at this
point too and we get a similar scene to
what plays out in the comics now one
missing thing I appreciated about the
comics is that we had an apple poster
pinned up in the background atom Eve is
obviously a play on Adam and Eve and
she's gaining knowledge like when they
bit into the Apple
Bridge
well that thought was worth bringing up
yeah and also the comics of the dogs
licking here so I appreciated that as
well anyway both go through Brandy we're
telling her the truth we're clearly
implying that Elias is her quote-unquote
father throughout the entry there's this
idea of what it means to have a family
and the conclusion of the episode set up
perfectly here now both conversations
come to a close with Elias telling her
not to use her powers but in the show
they had a surveillance drone to
heighten up the tension we also don't
get a returning home to her mother to
show she's been snicking out and if
further hammers home how alien that she
feels now Judo Eliza's Revelation she's
now more disconnected from her family
than ever and Ericsson's forces are also
closing in we get far more character
development with the bad guys whereas in
the comics they did sort of skip over
them Samantha is clearly caught up in
Eliza's words too and she goes looking
for him amongst the homeless communities
in the book we skipped all this and just
went immediately for from her leaving
the conversation into fighting kill
Cannon now ironically he's voiced by the
same guy that plays Samantha's dad in
the show and I don't know thematically
that's because both these guys look down
on her the similarities between Mark and
Samantha end up becoming more apparent
here too as kill Cannon is actually the
first supervillain in that both fought
nice little bit of graffiti in the scene
too and you can actually catch a mural
of War women on the wall now Adam Eve
sticks his feet at the floor just like
the comics and she also takes him out
using her abilities in the comics it was
at this point we go to the Pentagon to
get a riff on the scene that we had with
Ericsson before taking down Cal Cannon
was what alerted him of samanthaire and
we saw murdering the specimens to be
readied now from here salmonella ice go
to Bergamot which is where Mark ends up
working in the first season this was the
location he also discovered his powers
at and mirrored here Samantha now
learning the truth our lies lies that
Sam's mother was a valued lab partner
but we see that she was a homeless woman
that they run experiments on we actually
only got a single panel of hair getting
approached on the streets and the rest
of this backstory in the comics was
completely missing to me it really helps
to flesh out everything and it adds to
the themes centered around family
kirkman's often said he's cleaning up
the story for the show and doing things
with the hindsight of knowing the whole
plan it really works too and as she
finds out we can see a poster on the
wall for the green ghost now in the
comics issue one ended with her storming
away at this point an issue 2 picked up
with a fight between her and her family
in the comics we got a quick Cameo capes
Incorporated but I'm guessing they cut
this out just to streamline the story
kind of get a play on The Avengers
um fall back and um former perimeter or
something I need a perimeter as far back
as 39th should I take orders from you
[Music]
I need men in those buildings lead the
people down and away from their streets
we're gonna set up a perimeter all the
way down to 39th Street fall back and
former perimeter great idea
and leads to a big fight between her and
all her family in the show they're way
more monstrous than how they were in the
comics and I also think the fight
animations are incredible it has them
really busting out all the stocks to
bring us a thrilling fight and I have to
say invincible's fight animations are
absolutely incredible now both battles
end with it feeling like a loss and this
is due to all the characters withering
away before they eventually die atom Eve
will also create a sort of power armor
suit and it shows how versatile at our
powers are he's basically an overpowered
Green Lantern and the other phases are
right she's way better than they are now
they say Brandy words not her family but
we see at the end how Eve sees them as
that they do beat the crap out of her at
one point but she is saved by Elias and
this leads to phase two being The Last
One Alive in the end both Adam even
brandyworth had taken out by Erickson
which is when we learn the truth about
Samantha's mother stored in a
containment cell it's a horrifying fade
and she's been sentenced to her base
basically just being used as a womb it's
completely horrendous and in all honesty
if you know the story of Samantha then
you know her life is filled with tragedy
like this her adopted parents are of
course dicks and yeah lots of terrible
stuff happens with the character now
from here both her mother and
brandyworth are killed in front of her
and this forces her to go Super Saiyan
like how she does in the comics becoming
like the dark Phoenix she's now
completely Godlike and she erases both
the bad guy's memories in one Fell Swoop
in the comic she says to brand new Earth
and her mother I'm sorry mum and dad I
love you before flying off really plays
at the family angle and yeah I thought I
had that into point out all the family
connection now that also has a snake
crawling through her mask which I always
took the play on the Adam and Eve thing
that we brought up before let me know if
you agree but yeah that is kind of how I
interpreted it either way Upon returning
home we see that her parents haven't
forgotten her birthday and though they
made some of her cake she does see that
they still care for her just like in the
comics her dad says that the only family
she's got and she ends up changing the
photo of them to one of her
quote-unquote real family we end with a
line only when I've got in the comics
which is also in the show but yeah they
actually add something in that's a
really touching moment getting a hug
from her mother she promises it'll be
all right and it shows that she at least
cares for her now in addition to the
story we then get a little epilogue that
wasn't included in the source material
joining omniman we seriously returns
home and Mark runs in pretending to be
duct tape man hilarious way to end the
episode but it does come with a tragic
side cause we know what omniman is
eventually gonna go ruin he gets angry
for a second before he starts to face
palm as he of course knows it's not too
long before it's all gonna come crashing
down and this of course plays further
into the themes of family and how
Samantha is desperate to have won
whereas heel happily throws away it's a
brilliant wedding in the episode and
also our breakdown and what what a great
Standalone episode that really was I'm
really hoping this becomes a regular
thing and with a breaks in between
Seasons we get these sort of Standalone
stories there's lots of them in the
Invincible world as well and I think it
would be the perfect way to get these in
between the entries I hope you've
enjoyed us going through it too and if
you have then please hit the Thumbs Up
Button make sure you subscribe for the
breakdowns in November as well and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you'll get
early access to videos every single week
and it goes such a long way to helping
us out we also have a merch store I'll
write shopzeroaudition.com which sells
lots of nerdy inspired t-shirts at some
more we just launched a secret Invasion
slash Pulp Fiction inspired t-shirt so
if you want to head over there and help
us out then the links in the description
now if you want something else to watch
we've got a breakdown of the Marvel's
trailer linked on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way huge thank you for
sticking to the video I've been poor
I'll see you next time you take care
yourself peace